SPEAKER: From the
beginning, people
have been tinkering,
experimenting, taking things
apart, trying things out.
And when lots of people are able
to get involved in this process
and play around with
tools and technology,
it gets better for everyone.
Recently, this
has been happening
with artificial
intelligence, especially
with machine learning.
Lots of people are
getting involved,
exploring speech, language,
image recognition, and more.
And that work is being
applied in helpful ways.
In something like
Google Photos, you
can now just type "dancing"
to find all your pictures
of dancing.
But if you're curious and
want to play with this stuff
and you're poking
around things like this
trying to understand
how it all works,
it can be pretty intimidating.
That's why we've created a
site called AI Experiments.
It's a showcase for simple,
hands-on experiments that show
how machine learning can make
sense of all kinds of things
like sound--
[BIRD CALLS]
--language, music--
[PLAYS MUSIC]
--live video, everyday objects--
COMPUTER VOICE 1: Drink.
COMPUTER VOICE 2: Drink.
SPEAKER: --even in
different languages,
and your messy doodles.
COMPUTER VOICE 3: I see
frying pan or whale.
Oh, I know.
It's snowman.
SPEAKER: For each
experiment, there's
a simple video explainer
by the people who made it.
There are links to
open source code
to make it easier for others
to make new experiments.
And people can submit
what they make.
All of this is an effort to
make this technology more
accessible to everyone--
engineers, hobbyists, students,
anyone who's curious.
This way, anyone can get
inspired to start making things
with machine learning.
So come and start playing
at g.co/aiexperiments.